chimps you know I don't know if you know
this or not but chimps basically go to
war Jane Goodall discovered that a
couple of decades ago really really was
hard on her because she was kind of a
Rousseau lien so for those of you don't
know Joe jean-jacques rousseau is a
French philosopher and you know French
philosophers have a lawful lot of sins
on their conscience and of course we saw
was certainly one of them because
Rousseau was the first like what fully
articulate promoter of the idea that
human beings were basically good so you
know we had a good soul in a moral sense
but we were corrupted by her social
institutions you know so so you know as
far as Rousseau was concerned it was
kind of a noble savage idea you know
like the human being in their raw form
has a pure soul and then you know you
you give them to parents and you give
them to teachers and you know they get
into politics and there's group disputes
and then they get all corrupted you know
and well you know that's I don't even
want to say about that except that it's
absolutely wrong but it's it's the
appealing proposition if you're naive
optimist I mean first of all it doesn't
explain where malevolence comes from
because the people created the
institution so you know it just puts you
into an infinite regress chicken-and-egg
if the institutions are reprehensible
but the people who built them aren't
then where did the reprehensible
elements of the institutions come from
you know he might think it's an auto
generating consequence of organizing
people but you know it's a pretty
specious theory so I'm of course he had
a counterpart of philosophical
counterpart Thomas Hobbes and Hobbes
said basically exactly the opposite that
you know people were vicious and cruel
and unless you like put them in
straightjackets fundamentally and made
them obey then everything was going to
go immediately to hell you know and when
when you saw what happened in Iran after
the Americans waltzed in and the power
structure disintegrated do you know it
was a hell of a lot more like Hobbes
than it was like Rousseau right he took
out the tyrant at the top and it wasn't
like everybody got all peaceful and
loving all of a sudden it was like
absolute chaos reigned so you know of
course you can rationalize that but
anyways Rousseau by the way had five
children by
literate made that it was his mistress
he put every single one of them in
orphanages where of course they perished
because orphanages have Rousseau's times
were not exactly you know a luxury
resort and even up till the beginning of
the 20th century most children who were
under 1 years of age who were in care
institutions who died
partly disease and that sort of thing
but often because they just weren't
touched they weren't cared for
physically even if they were fed and you
know 200 years ago they weren't even fed
so anyway so you know but nonetheless
you know people have people maintained
the optimistic idea that human beings
were you know basically good and that
they were corrupted by institutions it's
a common idea among I think it's a very
common idea in the universities you know
because university people are always
complaining about the corrupt nature of
this institution in that institution you
know while they sit here in the warm
with the electricity on you know it's
surrounded by wealth that characterizes
maybe 1/10 of 1% of the entire world's
population and you know they complain
about how oppressed they are and how you
know nasty the institutions are it's
like yeah well you actually haven't been
to a nasty institution you know cuz
nasty institutions they get pretty damn
bad and most of the institutions in the
world are like that so it isn't exactly
clear that people are pristine in their
heart and then corrupted by institutions
you know although I'm sure that happens
happen to pans around for example so
anyways this has been a line of
philosophical speculation that's that's
that's I would say constituted one of
the unspoken fundamental assumptions of
of Western intellectuals in particular
and Jane Goodall thought you know in
many ways the same way she thought
chimps were basically you know they're
just animals they're okay they exist to
exist relatively peacefully with one
another you know even
carl rogers who i talked about a bit my
personality klaus you know he basically
thought that people were fundamentally
good and that institutions made them bad
but tom the problem is you look at
chimps and they're a fair bit like us
you know barnable is you can look at
them too and they're they're genetically
quite related to us and they're quite a
bit different than chimps but so we're
sort of a weird mixture of the two in
some sense but chimps like those things
there is no evidence that they really
have any internal control over the
regression at all you know there was a
horrible case about two years ago where
a woman was interacting with the chimp
and a tore her to pieces and they can do
that back like it took her face right
off and they have the strength of about
six men like an adult male chimp can
break a 300 pound test cable you know
those things are really really strong
and they're not friendly
you know like so in arnhem zoo for
example there has been a troop of chimps
there that have been followed by an
extremely brilliant part metrologist
named Fran's de Waal whose work I would
very highly recommend the wall is a very
smart guy and he's looked at the origins
of morality in chimpanzees you know from
a biological perspective it's very very
nice work very very clear-headed but you
know he's recounted absolutely horrific
stories of chimpanzee behavior so one of
the stories he talked about for example
was you know when you kind of have this
idea that there's a male chimp hierarchy
it's roughly true there's a female
hierarchy too but the males in the chimp
world anyways tend to be the dominant
one since you know you kind of think of
a dominant primate like a prizefighter
you know pretty much he's ruling because
of his physical prowess now that turns
out not to exactly be true but in this
particular case the guy who was running
the chimp troupe was a bit of a bully
and he wasn't very good at making
friends you know and that's not such a
good idea because no matter how tough
you are by yourself to weaker guys can
probably take you out and that's what
happened during friends to was
observations and to chimps attack the
leader and they had a coalition they
were grooming each other they repels you
know and chimps are pretty good at
remembering like reciprocal
relationships and having friendships
really like they have a very highly
social structure they just tore him
apart like the things they did to him
want to talk about and so chimps have
really no upper limit on their capacity
for aggression and when they hunt cuz
chips hunt and they like meat they often
hunt colobus monkeys and they they weigh
about 35 pounds like a cola this monkeys
a major league animal and need those
things alive and they scream while
they're being killed and that does not
slow the chimps down one bit so it's not
obvious that the chimp is really a
creature of a lot of empathy especially
the males
the females are likely more empathic
because they have to deal with infants
for longer periods of time what seems to
inhibit the aggression of male chimps
isn't anything they hold internally it
seems that when they get hyper
aggressive in the truth the troop gets
more and more agitated basically shuts
them down so you can imagine maybe
you're in a rough bar and some dingbat
who's you know half psychopathic and has
had two pints of alcohol is starting to
cause a tremendous amount of trouble and
he's not gonna show themself down but
the rest of the troop might and that
kind of means that the control over the
aggression is externalized it's not a
consequence of super-ego control we like
to think that we actually control our
own aggression but I'm not so sure about
that you know if you read things like
there's a great book a horrifying book
published about 20 years ago called The
Rape of Nanking which is while the woman
who wrote it committed suicide so that
sort of suffice us to tell you what The
Rape of Nanking is about and it's a
story about the Japanese in world war ii
going into a chinese kitty city called
Nanking where I believe about 350,000
people were killed in the Nazis in that
story were the good guys so you can
imagine the kind of brutality that might
mean being occurring there but there's
absolutely perfectly well documented
evidence suggesting that the Japanese
soldiers engaged in competitive
brutality you know and so really what
happened was the Japanese had been
pretty militarized by World War two and
they'd adopted a Prussian education
system and the Prussians and Germans you
know pre pre twentieth-century Germans
they were basically interested in
educating obedient soldiers you know
because it was a militaristic culture
and the Japanese kind of adopted that
because they were sick of being kicked
around by the Europeans pretty
successfully because they defeated the
Russians you know in the early stages of
rule
of the 20th century it was quite a shock
to everyone in Europe and you know cause
for great celebration in Japan and no
wonder but anyways they militarized the
hell out of their young men and taught
them basically that the Japanese were a
master race you know and that other
people were some humans it's a very
common human way of thinking by the way
I would say it's really the default way
that human tribes think about other
tribes you know I mean it's a little
more complicated than that because human
tribes tend to trade with other tribes
so it's not all demonization but a lot
of it is you know and if you look around
the world in the anthropological
literature what you see is that the
names that most tribes have for
themselves is something like that human
beings or the people you know indicating
that the rest of the people are breeding
people go to either barbarians or you
know they live out where the Sun is
being eaten by the dragon of the night
or something like that and you know the
word barbarian is a is a word that comes
from the Greeks making fun of how
non-greek spoke so anyways what good ol
fun was that the chimps like the chimp
adolescents in particular particularly
the males would patrol the the borders
of their territory in groups of three or
four and with often with a female or two
but the females didn't seem to be really
the the the they weren't they were more
part of the group rather than the
initiators but what the chimps would do
is if they found a chimp from another
troop even if that was a chimp that had
moved from their troop in the not too
distant past and joined another because
sometimes the male's leave and sometimes
they go to other troops if they
outnumbered them they would tear them to
pieces and it looked like that's why
they were doing the border patrol
they're out looking for trouble their
gangs roughly speaking they're looking
for trouble but the point of it is is
that and they would only attack if they
outnumbered you know cuz chips can I
wouldn't say they count but they have a
rudimentary notion of group size you
know I don't think you can count without
being able to verbalize but you can
estimate at a glance and so you know
when I mean when I say tear apart that's
exactly what I mean
there's no upper limit on the brutality
and so Goodall discovered that for
first and she didn't tell anybody about
it now she had her reasons I mean some
of them I think we really owe the lovely
chimps you know and fair enough but some
of it was also she thought that maybe
the chimps had been corrupted as a
consequence of their contact with human
beings and that their natural behavior
had been somehow transformed
you know and that's not it's reasonable
to be cautious if you're a scientist
before you go out and say hey chimps go
to war isn't that revolutionary because
it is right because it just it just ends
the idea that our warlike and malevolent
nature is a function of culture like if
chimps do it well what are they
perverted by their own culture I don't
think so you know I mean there are more
and less violent chimp cultures and
there are more and less violent baboon
cultures so there's some cultural
variation but since Goodall's time this
sort of behavior is being documented on
many many chimp troops so that's us in a
nutshell